Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Full Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 4 Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs
and references, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
very apropos that we're in the middle of Loki season
two episodes right now
And one of the big twists of those episodes are that
things are being turned into spaghetti
all over the place,
including people being turned into spaghetti.
care before spoilers,
if you haven't seen the Rick and Morty episode yet,
we'll start at the beginning. Work
our way through, shot
by shot, talking about Easter eggs
wtf moments, starting with the episode title.
That's Morty, which is a reference to the classic song
That's the Moiré by Dean Martin.
During this song there's a famous line that goes when
the stars make you drool just like a pasta fizzle.
That's the more a
the actual song is all about being in love,
but the episode is literally
about the eating of spaghetti.
Combined with the Soylent Green movie.
Like the whole idea that you're eating people,
basically,
they're couple other movie parodies
that they work in here, too.
Like, never Let me go along with all the different
justifications they come up with
for the creation of special quote unquote, spaghetti,
like on this planet,
How much of a person does someone have to be in order
for their body to turn into spaghetti after they die?
Like, what qualifies as a person?
Most of the episode,
I think, was taking aim at vegans and veganism,
like the whole concept of eating things
that come from living bodies during the cold open.
They reveal that the family's recently
been having weekly spaghetti night.
It seems like it's been going on for a while with Rick
bringing them spaghetti.
They all love it so much
that you can tell that something isn't right.
Like they're stupid,
happy in a way that's so over the top.
This something is clearly says
Jerry doesn't care that he's bombed his recent job
interview, confirming that he's still out of work
for the vast majority of the series.
Like however many seasons, it winds up burning.
I think that he will perpetually be out of a job.
Like maybe every once in a while
he'll briefly get a job,
but then probably be fired by the end of the episode
just so that Beth winds up being the only person
in the household that actually has a real weekly job
that she goes to to earn money To be fair, though,
Rick can technically make anything that they need
or just like magic it up using his science.
So money doesn't really matter to the family
that much.
summer loves the spaghetti so much
she throws her phone at the thought of it so hard
that it winds up smashing to pieces.
Jerry even trips on his way to the table.
He's so excited in as he explains here
Morty talks about later the idea is that
the spaghetti nights brought the family together
in a way that nothing had before.
They put all their differences aside
and just enjoy time together.
one of the metaphors of the episode
is how far you're willing to go
to get that kind of feeling,
that closeness with the people around you.
Like if something that was bringing you
closer together with your loved ones, your friends,
and you've had something behind
that was bad, how bad would it have to be in order
for you to throw away that closeness
with your friends and family?
generally with all the veganism shots
they take during the episode,
you could think of the spaghetti
as being kind of like veal.
Like there are a couple other metaphors
you can make, but the whole idea that you're basically
eating a baby lamb and it tastes really good.
what does it take before eating that baby lamb
becomes distasteful to you?
turns out at the end of the episode they reveal it's
seeing the entire life history put on screen,
like seeing all the memories In real life, though,
the whole idea is that
veal is like this delicacy
eaten, celebrated all over the world,
whereas vegans refuse to eat the meat of any living
creature, mostly on moral grounds.
Some people are vegans for health related reasons,
like there's some deficiency
or some genetic condition they have
that doesn't allow them to eat certain types of meat.
but mostly
veganism is looked at as being a moral choice.
during the episode, they have a bunch of jokes
about the family
showing mock shame at the thought
of eating people spaghetti like a lot of meat eaters
in general in real life saying, yes, it's terrible
that something had to die
for me to get this tasty meal, but it tastes so good
it just like in the episode,
the family doesn't really care about
where the spaghetti comes from
that much like they pretend to care,
but they don't really care.
in real life, most people do not care
that cheeseburgers come from cows.
They just like their cheeseburgers
Morty then learns the dark truth
behind the spaghetti that comes from dead bodies.
in the way Rick described it,
it sounds like the spaghetti generated
from a single person's body, from like a single adult
person is more than enough to feed
a family of five several different helpings
like it's a lot of spaghetti generated per person.
There are a lot of funny moments in the episode
where they get really into the weeds
and like the whole logic behind the creation
of spaghetti generally the whole twisted the episode
like something the family enjoying that Rick brings
them secretly having some terrible origin bite.
It has been used in the show many times,
as has the trope of Morty
kind of ruining something that Rick is doing
or trying to do they're making things worse
and forcing Rick to help him fix it.
They used to be like every single episode
in the early seasons of the show,
like Morty would always wind up ruining something
trying to high road Rick,
and then Rick would wind up having to fix it
because he makes things worse.
showing Morty that he never should have messed with it
in the first place or questioned it.
none of the intro scenes were featured
in this week's episode.
We still have six episodes left this season,
so maybe we'll see one at some point.
It would be weird if none of the intro scenes
wind up in any of the episodes.
Rick takes Morty to the dimension where he gets
the spaghetti from, explained the whole logic
of the episode.
In this reality,
people who kill themselves turn into spaghetti.
The even funnier thing was when they had him explain
the logic behind how a human body could turn itself
into spaghetti in the first place and the spaghetti
sauce on top of that with the meatballs.
as he
explains, the rationale is that their intestines
transform into the pasta part
in the organs, turn into the sauce
and the meatballs part
requiring a fatal amount of cortisol
Rick takes him to the hospital
where he's been stealing the bodies
from where he's been pretending to be.
Doctor Hot penis.
Probably also getting with some of the staff
there on the side.
Why you use that name?
being on a first name basis with the security guard
as it's meant to show that he's been going there
for a long time, that they've been having
spaghetti nights for a long time.
when he says Morty has space cancer,
I would not be surprised if that's actually a thing
in the Rick and Morty multiverse.
Like a specific type of cancer,
you could actually get.
they explain on this planet
the concept of spaghetti does not exist like pasta.
Spaghetti sauce have never existed.
then seems weirder than the spaghetti twist itself.
Rick neutralizing himself, I think is just meant to be
a bit about senior moments.
Like he gets confused about where he is.
I hate it when that happens,
implying that he's done that to himself many times.
also use the whole neuro laser bit
backdooring Morty's mind
blowers explaining that he does this to Morty
all the time.
He raises his memories all the time.
Later in the episode,
he also makes a literal Men in Black reference
when he talks about a racing Morty's mind again
so that he'll forget where spaghetti came from.
I think the reason why he didn't do that
at the beginning of the episode is one, because that
would have completely negated the entire episode,
like there wouldn't be an episode if he had done that.
But also because he does genuinely care about Morty
and wants to indulge him like normally.
If Rick did not care about Morty,
he wouldn't humor him.
Like,
he wouldn't have taken into this plant to show him
what was going on
when he mentions the name Corner number one.
That name joke is just about extras
and background stars on TV shows.
Sometimes on TV shows they'll be a bunch of extras
or background characters in the only
give them generic names like Handsome Man
Number three or Garbage Man number two.
Usually when actors play characters, even if it's like
a really small bit or just a couple of lines.
If they give the character an actual real name,
the person's supposed to get paid way more money.
Contractually. Just the way that Hollywood works.
so when they name someone corner number one,
it means they don't have to pay them as much money
regardless of what they're doing in the episode,
Rick reveals that his moral line
like we're the point eating people
becomes a problem for him is when they're given names.
This gets into more veganism jokes like giving the cow
that you ate to get the burger a name
Rick lies when he implies Morty's only alive
because he doesn't turn delicious when he dies.
Like Rick wouldn't ever eat Morty,
even if he didn't like it that much,
he probably wouldn't eat them Notice
the woman at the door there hears
everything that he says and reacts to it
as he's walking by like, What did you just say?
I'm not sure what this cross is supposed to mean.
Like, what is their religion on this planet?
But that's basically a symbol of their religion
says Morty is the only person
to speak up for Lawrence here.
I think the idea is that
he was meant to be a really bad person,
and that's why nobody wants to speak on his behalf.
this guy records his speech
explaining what's been going on with the spaghetti,
which gets back to their planets leader.
then reveals the truth to the rest of the family.
And they obviously all pretend to be shocked
but don't really care
because they enjoyed the spaghetti so much.
Like if you're making the veganism jokes here,
they love the cheeseburgers
then they all start clowning on Morty.
Like, how dare you ruin this for us, Morty?
Jerry also reveals
that something similar happened with octopus to them.
And it has something to do with fascists
in the United States.
Like somehow they're behind octopus
or they turn into octopus when they kill themselves.
You can let me know what you think
this means about octopus on this planet.
Morty enjoys some of their version of Pornhub,
some farm girl
therapist who loves depression for some reason.
I always love these little bits on Rick and Morty,
like things that don't totally make sense.
Like what? What is this?
Then this spaghetti Planet leader brings Morty
back to explain to them
the whole concept of eating spaghetti from dead bodies
because they're looking to profit from it.
Basically, you could call this the show
clowning on the entire meatpacking
industry with jokes about them
trying to come up with positive sounding slogans
that eating whatever it is they're producing
sounds less gruesome.
also notice that the rant for the ship
looks just like a tongue in the shit.
Looks like a person eating another person, which is
just a callback to the whole theme of the episode.
Like you're eating other people.
even though the planet seems like it's very similar
to Earth,
notice in the background
there's like a crazy looking horse creature.
Morty is a little joke about typical earthlings
is just the idea
that everybody in real
life is supposed to feel special no matter what.
Like, No, no, no.
We have to tell everybody that they're special.
then they get Morty to consent to being an ambassador
so that they can get his permission
to use his face in the marketing of the spaghetti.
in the episode starts to play with the whole idea
of the moral line that Morty draws in the episode,
like what people giving their permission to be eaten
make it
okay to eat the spaghetti in the answer in
his case is yes.
Like Morty asks for the spaghetti to be taken to go.
The ethical spaghetti is also meant to clown on vegan
vegetarian industry
just because oftentimes
the same corporation who kill all the regular animals
like the regular meatpacking industry,
just slap an ethical label on in jack up the price
when in reality
you're eating the exact same type of meat
The Parmesan joke is a callback
to the season six opener.
Rick reveals how
Morty has made things worse on the planet
using his face and the slogans to market
the spaghetti, turning the entire planet
into a glorified spaghetti factory in the quality
of life just going way, way down, basically
engineering more ways on the planet to convince people
to kill themselves in order to produce more spaghetti
so that they can earn more money.
I love the whole side
bit here about single origin spaghetti like it's
not spaghetti from a bunch of different bodies
mixed together in the same can.
Rick reveals that Walmart has several locations
throughout the universe.
their cans have a recording
from the people they came from.
And obviously the whole bit here is about the person
being a cannibal and killing people in real life.
And now his death is super ironic
because he's being eaten by a bunch of other people
when they go back to the spaghetti planet,
the end is nigh sign is a Watchmen Easter egg
there are bunch of jokes on the billboards
about therapists getting degrees certified
specially for spaghetti.
Like they'll become trained to convince people to
kill themselves instead of doing the opposite of that.
in apparently the evil organization
managing all this spaghetti production
is called the Better Spaghetti Bureau.
I think that's just meant to be a parody
of the American Association of Meat Processors,
which is like the organization
that manages meatpacking in the United States.
this is, where the episode kind of turns
into more of a Soylent Green kind of parody
where the entire planet is consuming
or selling spaghetti in some way.
they even have the slogan from the Soylent
Green movie later in the episode.
It's made from people
These are making jokes about everything that they done
the planet to convince people to kill themselves.
Morty thinks it's anyway.
Rick reveals it's actually morning zoo news teams
just patter,
just the banter that the TV show characters
have talking to each other.
boring people so badly
that they want to kill themselves
A bunch of terrible reality
shows like Infidelity Island, where couples
just cheat on each other, Siamese twin sisters
who somehow can't be separated
in a really bad version of Animal Planet
where the animals just kill each other.
Rick's old Discovery
Channel joke is also them clowning on the company
that now owns Adult Swim and owns the show.
So Adult Swim was owned by Time Warner Warner
Brothers, which combined with the Discovery networks.
So now the actual company that owns
everything is Warner Brothers Discovery.
There was a huge debacle with that
the last couple of years.
Then they reveal if they stopped the spaghetti trade,
the planet will also wind up being destroyed.
So it's kind of a damned
if they do, damned if they don't.
Situation and Rick agrees to fix Morty's muck up.
Morty also promises to never question
any of Rick's gifts or ideas or schemes ever again.
But they say it's only for two weeks
because it's like the whole foundation of the show.
Is Morty trying to high road Rick then
completely mucking things up and making it even worse
so that Rick has to fix things and prove to Morty
why he never should have messed with it
in the first place or questioned them.
basically it's like them saying
it'll be just for the next two episodes Morty
Whole Keith
Ranieri reference is to the next IBM called.
There were a ton of documentaries about it
the last couple of years.
You can watch, but most people remember the Colts
because one of the most famous people
that were involved with that was Allison
Mack, who played Chloe Sullivan on Smallville.
She went to jail for a while for that.
if you listen to Michael Rosenbaum and Tom Welling's
podcast, they've talked about it in the past too,
like how they basically had no idea what was going on
when they were making the Smallville TV show.
they had the whole bit
about how far away from an actual person
something can be in order for it to become spaghetti.
this is also a bit about companies in real life
trying to come up with more ethical alternatives
to traditional me in all them
being kind of ridiculous, like Rick and Morty
trying to create their version of Beyond Meat
or plant based meat, like impossible beef, basically.
end. I love how pissed off Rick is here, but how he
kind of turns on a dime when Morty suggests cloning.
Like, are you suggesting I come up with this crazy bit
using my cloning technology and he's super into it?
this basically turns into a direct
Never let me go movie parody.
What you see in the episode
is basically the plot of the movie in the movie,
a bunch of kids learned that they're destined
to become organ donors,
like they only exist to become organ donors
for other people.
Rick also clarifies that on this planet,
a person has to understand
the concept of life and death in order
for them to turn into spaghetti.
seems like a weird qualification, like
some psychological aspect into becoming spaghetti.
when he mentions the trolley problem,
that's actually a real life psychology goal.
Ethical dilemma.
And one of the problems your make the question
if you should pull a lever on train tracks to divert
a runaway trolley onto a sidetrack if it means killing
only one person instead of killing several people.
like the whole idea is that you're meant
to have to decide whether or not it's better
to kill only one person or kill a bunch of people
Either way, you wind up killing someone.
That's the ethical dilemma.
in it's meant to dovetail with Rick's moral message
at the end of the episode where he basically says
There's no right answer, like You're damned
if you do, damned if you don't,
and you have to exist like you have to eat.
So even if it does mean doing something bad,
sometimes you still have to do it.
then Rick basically creates
this universe version of boneless chicken.
Only it's people like it's torsos.
somehow this winds up being worse, though.
And they do this Soylent Green
parody like it's made up people doesn't last too long
until a bunch of protesters who come in
from different sides of different positions,
people upset
that boneless people aren't truly the real thing
and they want spaghetti from real people in others
who want rights and freedom for the boneless people.
zoom in and hands in the background here
to one of the protesters looks kind of like
Krang from Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
then Rick basically fixes everything
by showing everyone the lifetime of memories
from a person causing them to be disgusted
by the spaghetti, turning everyone off it forever.
so it's kind of like them joking
that if you could see, like the life history of a cow,
like the entire life history, you might not want
to eat that cheeseburger quite as badly.
love, the whole montage here, too.
They were a couple of really funny moments
and a couple twisted. It takes.
One of my favorite parts, though, is the relationship
subplot here that's going on.
the most part, these memories seem pretty trophy
like you can kind of see the way the arc is going,
but then all of a sudden
it veers into this whole infidelity and divorce
subplot like, Whoa, what is going on here?
This is crazy.
basically convincing his old girlfriend to leave her
family and join him for the rest of their lives.
Like, wow, this has some twists.
He also basically winds up
creating this world's version of Legos.
So got pretty rich,
as you can see, from his crazy mansion,
living the dream with his old girlfriend eating jam
till he dies.
also the whole idea here that Rick had a secret
euthanasia bunker set up on this plan and it looks
super old like he created this years ago for whatever
reason, and it just ready to go at a moment's notice.
And how he tells Morty not to question the logic of it
like it's his year. Why?
Why worry about it in the whole idea
is that even in another reality with like a vacuum
cleaner version of Rick,
he also has the exact same room like vacuum cleaner.
Rick came up with the exact same idea
and whether the exact same
circumstances is the C 137 version of Rick.
Like this is some fundamental part of Rick
in every single reality when they start panning
around the planet during the speech notice of the bar
while everyone is fighting each other to the death,
one of them is just trying to get free
drinks like this is crazy, but I need an extra drink.
Kitty Hawk was the Wright Brothers first
successful flight of the world's first full airplane.
Technically,
it was the first sustained flight by a manned
heavier than air powered and controlled aircraft.
An airplane basically Going way back in history,
people had actually flown
through the air for short periods in small aircraft
long before this.
But like this was meant to be the first working
full airplane.
in the song that they played over
that montage of memories was Live
Forever by Oasis,
which they also play in the Post-Credits scene.
I love it in the memory of high school
in the trophy case, here is a sports ball.
they also misspell regional champions on here too
apparently at this high school
they're not so great at spelling when he winds up
flunking out of school and his life sort of devolves.
Notice that he's drinking wine from a can
so you can tell your life is at rock
bottom as you're drinking wine from a
can in a once it's over.
Even though Ray kind of laments
the whole moral conundrum of everything,
he still seems like he enjoys the spaghetti.
Like, Yep, it's great.
But like I said, Rick's whole moral message to Morty
at the end of the episode is that life itself
is fundamentally wrong in death is right,
but you can't really side
with death because that would be
the most depressing way to live ever.
therefore you have to live in in order to live,
you have to eat.
So sometimes you do have to eat the spaghetti, so to
speak, and ultimately not to worry about it that much.
I don't question it that much,
even though he does seem like he understands
the whole moral conundrum because he kind of sighs
when he eats the spaghetti like, Yeah, this sucks,
but I still like the spaghetti.
then they end the episode with that whole bit about
the very definitely not ethical Salisbury steaks.
Like they have some super dark secret behind them so
bad that would make everybody want to kill themselves.
But the family loves the taste so much.
And they love the closeness that eating them together
brings them did.
They agree that they will never question
Rick bringing them something like this ever again.
Like, sometimes
it's just a bunch of really good cheeseburgers
and it doesn't matter where they came from.
during the post-credits scene, they basically repeat
the exact same events that just happened
in another reality with a planet of a living vacuum
cleaners who learn their bags come dead.
Bodies of a group
like Marvel Creature like this is basically Groot,
and this is meant to be a vacuum cleaner
version of Rick revealing the truth to them.
kind of like the whole concept of Hammer Morty.
Like in every reality, it's
not always a human looking version of Rick.
Like, sometimes they're meant to be other things.
basically ending the episode with them
all, throwing up the same way.
But because they're vacuum cleaners,
they eject their bags of dirt everywhere.
Let me know in the comments how many of you are hungry
for spaghetti after this episode?
Don't worry. That does not make you a monster.
no judging here, no judgment. There were a bunch
of Easter eEggs and references though.
So if you spotted any in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video, just write them
below in the comments. And my full Episode
5 video we'll post next week after they release it.
there's a bunch of big stuff happening this week.
My Loki Episode 6 video we'll post
after they release it
Click here for that
I'll update the link as soon as I post that and click here
for all my Rick and Morty episode videos
Thank you so much for watching everyone.
Enjoy your spaghetti
and I'll see you guys in the next one!